there's a really good article in slate
by Jeremy Stahl called the total
humiliation of Dr Oz and Trump in
Pennsylvania and there's a couple of
different perspectives about what took
place in Pennsylvania but a great
starting point is this article by Jeremy
Stahl and Jeremy Stahl points out most
importantly fetterman beat new
jersey-based crudite loving TV celebrity
Dr Mehmet Oz and Stahl correctly points
out it wasn't a guarantee
fetterman ran several points behind the
winning Democratic gubernatorial
candidate Josh Shapiro it's easy to
imagine that a strong Republican
candidate could have beaten fetterman in
a race that may well determine control
in the Senate indeed Republicans had a
real opportunity to select that strong
Challenger specifically the relatively
moderate hedge fund manager and former
Treasury Department official David
McCormick who finished second in the
Republican primary by just 951 votes
Stahl makes the case and I believe he's
right that were it not for Trump's
endorsement of Oz McCormick would have
won the primary and it is completely
plausible that if McCormick wins the
primary he defeats fetterman it quite
literally if the Senate ends up 50 50 in
favor of Democrats because of Kamala
Harris as the tie-breaking vote you
could accurately blame Trump for losing
Republicans the Senate by jumping in and
endorsing Oz rather than McCormick or
staying out of it altogether
a couple of different things here
one of the aspects to this race that got
very ugly was essentially the stroke
shaming that took place by many
Republicans after John fetterman
suffered a stroke months ago
and struggling with auditory processing
not cognitively but struggling with
auditory auditory processing the Oz
campaign uh put out some ads ridiculing
fetterman's Health although Oz
personally said it wasn't me doing that
but it was still attached to the
campaign
um at the debate
even some of my viewers never mind the
Republicans we're kind of making fun of
fetterman for the way that he was
speaking
and one of the crazy things is you know
they were out there calling him and I I
apologize for these terms they were
saying he he's he's a [ __ ] people were
saying he based on how he's speaking
he's a [ __ ] uh he's brain damaged blah
blah blah blah
um
he won
okay
at some point
when it came to Trump lost to Biden who
was in his basement
that's not believable the flip side of
it is how humiliating is it that Trump
lost to a guy who didn't leave his
basement right like if if anyone
concedes that that's what Biden did it
makes it all the more embarrassing that
Trump lost to that guy now of course
they say he didn't really lose it was
fraud put that aside for a moment for
all their criticisms of fetterman which
include just making fun of the guy for a
medical problem that he had doesn't it
make it all the more embarrassing to Oz
that he couldn't beat the guy that they
describe as a mentally [ __ ] person
it should really make them think wow
these candidates are terrible now they
may ultimately start claiming fraud in
some of them are anecdotally or whatever
the case may be but crudite did not take
oz to Victory and to me the really scary
thing is that Oz didn't lose by more
when you look at what happened in
Florida DeSantis won by 19. that is
brutal the polling had the santus up
like 11 which would be bad enough and
ultimately DeSantis loss by like 19 and
that is signaling the strength of the
DeSantis wing of the party on the other
hand
Oz lost he didn't even lose by that much
and he should be glad about that but
Pennsylvania rapidly becoming the
biggest humiliation for Trump and
Republicans and we're going to talk
about the endorsement record a little
bit later just remember endorsing
incumbents and republican nominees in
red districts is not a difficult way to
run up your score for endorsements when
you have actual tough races where the
primary winner might actually affect who
wins in the case of McCormick versus
versus Oz it almost certainly did
Trump's record is a disaster and this is
why Rupert Murdoch and some others are
pulling the rip cord and trying to get
the hell out of here make sure that you
are subscribed to the David Pacman show
on YouTube or that you've liked our
Facebook page or that you're following
us on Twitch that's where all of the
streams will take place the upcoming
stream in support of Raphael Warnock
will be on those three platforms the
Trump announcement next Tuesday will be
on those platforms election results on
December 6th we'll be streaming on those
platforms make sure you're following
subscribe to whatever it is all
completely free